[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous bonsoir
Grégory bonsoir mathil ravi d'être avec
vous pour cette nouvelle émission de fin
d'année on est sur notre 31 pour cette
émission spéciale Noël quel est le
programme ce soir alors ce soir si vous
êtes du joueur retardataire et que vous
n'avez pas encore fait votre cadeau de
Noël pas de panique nous vous donnons
quelques idées pour faire plaisir à
votre entourage et en plus c'est du 100
% local vous pouvez également disposer
des ma yvelinois sur votre table le
département compte de nombreux produits
du terroir pour vous régaler durant les
fêtes gourmandise garantie et comme on a
pensé à tout l'une de nos invité Sophie
benami vous donnera des astuces pour
booster votre digestion après les repas
copieux la période de Noël c'est aussi
l'occasion de passer des bons moments en
famille ou entre amis dans cette
émission tv78 vous livre sa sélection
des idées de sorties à faire pendant les
vacances au programme compte histoire ou
encore spectacle de Noël nous sommes
aussi partis à la découverte d'un
nouveau jeu à Saint-Quentin en Eveline
la quiz room enfin on vous fera réviser
vos classiques j'espère que vous êtes
calés en musique de Noël parce qu'on va
les redécouvrir à la flute de pan George
Schmith le spécialiste mon mondial de
cet instrument va nous jouer quelques
morceaux en direct et il est en plateau
avec nous bonsoir George bonsoir bonsoir
vous allez je le disais à l'instant nous
jouer dans quelques instants des
morceaux de Noël à la flute de pan on a
hâte de voir ça et d'autres invités dans
le 78 spécial fin d'année alors il y en
a une qui est juste derrière moi voilà
vous l'apercevez c'est Sophie benami on
va la benabi on va la présenter tout à
l'heure mais en tout cas elle pourrait
être une allié de poids justement
pendant cette période de repas copieux
cette période de fête de fin d'année oui
faire une petite détoxe pendant ou après
les f ça peut toujours servir Michel
midoro bonsoir bonsoir journaliste de la
rédaction de tv78 vous allez nous donner
quelques idées de produits du terroir
yvelinois à mettre à notre table et oui
il y en a beaucoup hein on peut faire un
repas 100 % evvilois on a hâarir ça
aussi et en face de vous il y a Clara de
Frutos alors qui nous a rejoint cette
saison sur tv78 la peti nouvelle donc
voilà vous êtes la petite nouvelle et
c'est votre première émission Noël ce
soir ouais très impressionné impatiente
ouais impressionné j'espère que je vais
être à la hauteur de vos attentes mais
je suis très contente d'être là et bien
sûr on n'oublie pas les idées de sorties
à faire pendant les vacances Gabriel
Gontier bonsoir bonsoir ce sera avec
vous et donc ce sera aussi tout à
l'heure dans cette émission spécial Noël
et c'est bien sûr un plaisir he Clara
aussi d'être avec vous en plateau voilà
on vous a adressé le programme tous nos
invités presque tous il y aura également
quelques surprises au menu du 78 spécial
faite de fin d'année le 78 fin d'année
c'est c'est parti sur
[Musique]
tv78 et on va prendre tout de suite la
direction de Saint-Germain au lait pour
retrouver sur place l'une des
journalistes de la rédaction de tv78
c'est Régine ralèche que vous voyez à
l'écran bonsoir
Régine bonsoir Grégory accompagné pour
les moyens techniques de Julien Leroi
vous vous trouvez au sein du Village de
Noël installé dans la
ville exactement et je me place à l'abb
pierre de portcau tout près de la mairie
de Saint-Germain en laai donc vous
l'avez dit le village de Noël se tient
ici jusqu'au 31 décembre et on peut y
trouver beaucoup de choses notamment des
spécialités culinaires des patinoires et
également des ateliers pour les
enfants merci Régine on va vous
retrouver tout à l'heure un peu plus
tard dans cette émission vous serez
notamment auprès des artisans qui sont
dans ce marché de Noël ce village de
Noël installé à Saint-Germain en la
j'ai entendu un bruit Grégory vous êtes
sûr ah je crois que ça frappe voulez que
j'aille
ouvririzar qui nous dérange en pleine
émission de Noë je vaisessayer de pas
gêner la caméra pour voir qui c'est
est-ce que ce serait pas une surprise
que vous nous avez préparé
Grégory on va voir on va voir qui
c'est ah bonsoir Père Noël c'est le Père
Noël qui nous rejoint dans le 7ère vous
prie allezy allez vous
installer allezy prenez sal TV 78
bonsoir bonsoir vous
venez Gabri voyage mais je suis ravi
d'être avec vous ça va c'était pas trop
dur le voyage non j'ai l'habitude pas
trop fatigant on vous laisse vous serrer
à Gabriel juste pour que vous puissiez
bien apparaître à la camé et que on
puisse bien prouver à nos jeunesinois
que vous êtes bien en cher avec nous en
plateau ce soir voilà alorsah première
question Père Noël est-ce que les
enfants ont été sages cette année
écoutez dans la grande majorité oui mais
mais il reste quelques exceptions alors
il leur reste quelques dodo pour se
rattraper jusqu'à mon
passage tout n'est pas perdu le message
que je passe aux enfants pas très sage
tout n'est pas
perdu vous avez encore 5 jours c
dodo et n'oubliez pas je suis au courant
de ce que vous faites donc vos
parents ils aimeraient bien que je
puisse vous c'est des cadeaux d'accord
donc à vous de jouer donc Gabrielle qui
ne savait pas si elle avait été assez
sage cette année il reste encore une
chance il reste encore r d'c C dodo
alors est-ce que la légende elle dit
vrai est-ce que vous mettez du charbon
dans les chaussettes des enfants qui
sont pas passage bah
écoutez je je reste taquin je reste
taquin je peux effectivement des fois il
m'arrive de mettre un petit peu de
charbon dans les dans les chaussettes
des enfants à la place à la place
effectivement de friandise bon voilà le
message est clair et sans ambigué soyez
SAG soyez SAG voilà et est-ce que les
enfants peuvent vous donner du lait
pendant votre tourné quand vous apportez
les cadeaux alors ils peuvent c'est un
peu une légende mais c'est une légende
ou pas fin non mais jeis vous avouer je
suis extrêmement gourmand alors lorsque
j'arrive dans une maison et qu'il y a un
verre de lait et quelques cookies au
chocolat je vous avoue que je prends le
temps malgré vot gourmandis préféré les
cookies ah les cookies au chocolat avec
un petit ver de lait je prends le temps
de déguster et après je continue ma
tournée donc n'hésitez pas oui je sais
ce qu'il me reste à
faire j'espère que le message est passé
mais d'ailleurs est-ce que les cadeaux
sont prêts ah bien bien sûr bien sûr ça
y est tout est prêt voilà ils sont tous
chargés sauf pour les enfants où on
n'est pas sûr encore qu'il soit très SAG
donc tous les enfants sages la la la la
haute est pleine et puis après au
dernier moment d'accord je vais
effectivement pouvoir charger
les cadeaux pour celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas été complètement sages je me
sens un petit peu visé là donc la ha
c'est quasiment pleine la tournée
mondiale est prête il y a les derniers
ajustements qui seront fait au dernier
moment au dernier moment voilà en
fonction de l'attitude des enfants ou
des ou des un petit peu plus grand hein
voilà alors moi je me suis toujours posé
cette question comment est-ce que vous
faites pour construire tous ces cadeaux
parce qu'il y en a ils sont nombreux les
cadeaux bien sûr alors en fait moi ce
que je fais surtout c'est le design les
idées parce qu'en fait je regarde un
petit peu avec quoi s'amusent les
enfants et les moins et est un petit peu
plus un petit peu plus jeune un petit
peu moins jeune et après derrière j'ai
toute une armée de lutin dans mon usine
qui fabrique effectivement tous les
désirs des enfants et des grands voilà
voilà tout seul évidemment ce serait
tout à fait impossible ils font pas trop
de bêtises les lutins ah on les laisse
seul alors parce que je crois que chez
Michel midoro font efftivement moi j'ai
un petit lutin chez moi le lu lutin
farceur effectivement je sais pas pour
ceux qui connaissent ou connaissent pas
on reçoit un lutin chez soi pendant la
période qui précède Noël et vous les
récupéz c'est ça à la fin quand vous
récupérez les cadeau lors de ma tournée
je dépose le cadeau et je récupère le
lutin et ils sont partis en vacances
c'est bien ça
pendant voilà ils ont travaillé toute
l'année ENF tout est prêt donc c'est un
petit peu leur récompense et comme ils
sont un petit peu farceurs bah
finalement voilàs en temps ils font des
petites bêtises de la nu
il Vang gteant que vous DZ temps il vont
jouer avec le chat et mais voilà ça
reste toujours dans un bon esprit nous
on donnera des conseils tout à l'heure
pour rester en forme pendant cette
période de fête c'est quoi votre secret
à vous cette longévité écoutez un régime
alimentaire som toute le restant de
l'année tout à fait cordial mais mais un
peu frugal tout de même bon alors
évidemment ça me permet de d'avoir les
excès pendant la tournée de cookies
évidemment il y a pas de secret et après
je fais tout de suite beaucoup plus
attention le restant de l'année alors
juste vous êtes aidé par de nombreux
lutins mais la Mère Noël elle fait quoi
dans tout ça oh la Mère Noël ell mett
beaucoup dans le traitement des
courriers d'accord parce que nous
recevons tout tous les courriers toutes
les listes de tous les enfants et puis
des grands euh il y a énormément de
travail et donc effectivement benah elle
m'aide à répondre parce que nous nous
voulons répondre à toutes les à T tous
les courrier des enfants voilà donc ne
vous inquiétez pas la Mère Noël est
également très très bien occupée J-5
désormais av votre grande tournée en
tout cas merci beaucoup Père Noël d'être
revenu en plate on sait que vous êtes
très occupé en ce moment et vous avez
fait un petit détour par tv78 on était
vraiment ravi d'être avec vous mais
cétait vraiment un grand plaisir juste
un petit aparté vous avez bien reçu ma
lettre sur la console de jeux oui bien
sûr oui oui l' d'accord juste pour
savoir pour et vous avez bien reçu mon
message pour les cookies
oui donc effectivement nous avons tous
bien reçu les éléments qu'il fallait
alors est-ce que vous savez que vous
inspirez de nombreux ivelinois on est
parti du côté de Montini le Bretonneux à
la rencontre de marieange et de Gérald
ces deux habitants de Montini le
Bretonneux ont construit leur propre
village de Noël dans leur salon en
miniature bien sûr regardez bonjour on
est à Montini dans le dans le séjour de
marieange et Gérald et je vais vous
présenter notre notre village de Noël on
a démarré en 2017 et aujourd'hui on est
fier de vous montrer notre village donc
là en fait on a réparti par par scène on
essaie de reprendre un petit peu le les
temps et l'espace lesqu de 5tin avoir
une petite idée locale on a essayer
d'avoir une continuité dans les
différents plans donc on reste toujours
sur la ville un quartier un petit peu
plus chic puisqueen fait ça c'est des
dernières pièces qui viennent des
États-Unis avec des belles belles
réalisations si on regarde en fait vous
avez la bibliothèque à l'intérieur c'est
magnifique de la ville on bascule sur la
fête foraine avec l'entrée du du village
parc marieange bon vous avez différents
stands on retrouve le Grand 8 les
autoamponneuses le tagadac le bateau la
grande roue la patinoire ensuite ben du
coup on avance sur le village le village
est plutôt scindé en deux derrière vous
avez une partie un petit peu village
typique et plutôt village montagne pour
après arriver sur la vraiment la partie
montagne avec une partie vente sapin
avec le téléphérique qui rejoint
aujourd'hui on diffuse on diffuse notre
pe village par vidéo en fait on peut
retrouver sur je sais pas si on peut
citer YouTube Marie an parc 2022 et il y
aura Marie an parc
[Musique]
2023 voilà pour ce village de Noël vous
avez vu vous inspirer des ivelinois
venez avec moi Père Noël je vais vous
raccompagner merci encore d'avoir été
avec nous merci beaucoup Père Noël à
très vite bonne tournée merci beaucoup
j'étais sage
hein au revoir rir au revoir Père Noël
au
revoir et moi je vais aller m'installer
avec Sophie benabi qui est notre invité
Mathilde si vous me le permettez voilà
je m'installe dans notre petit salon de
tv78 alors vous êtes praticienne en
naayour Veda guoncour bonsoir déjà alors
vous partagez vos astuces sur les
réseaux sociaux sur votre compte qui
s'appelle Les Aventures verte de Sophie
qui compte plus de 40000 abonnés sur
Instagram et on va parler avec vous donc
de l'Ayurveda qui sera sans doute un un
alliier pour nos ivelinois durant ces
fêtes de fin d'année est-ce que vous
pouvez déjà dire en quelques mots c'est
quoi l'Ayurveda oui bien sûr alors c'est
une médecine en fait indienne qui prend
en compte l'être dans sa globalité et
qui donne une grande part en fait à
l'alimentation pour pouvoir prendre soin
de soi alors on aura l'occasion de
parler tout à l'heure des bienfaits sur
le corps humain de l'Ayurveda alors il y
a un bienfait qui est en tout cas on
peut l'avancer déjà digestif il peut
nous être utile pendant la la période de
fête alors vous avez vous êtes venu avec
quelques petits ingrédients parce que
vous allez nous préparer un apéritif
Ayour véi qui va nous aider justement à
bien passer ses fêtes à se détoxifier le
corps après les les repas copieux ben
expliquez-moi ce que vous allez nous
préparer là oui alors c'est à base en
fait de trois ingrédients donc c'est
extrêmement facile à refaire donc du
gingembre du citron et du sel rose de
l'Himalaya et en fait c'est ce qu'on
appelle un Dipana en Ayurveda c'est un
apéritif qui va aider à bien métaboliser
le repas parce que on va avoir pas mal
de choses grasses lourdes frite sur la
table et donc ça va permettre justement
d'allumer un petit peu ce feu digestif
pour éviter de sentir en kyosé d'avoir
les léthargies de piquer un petit peu du
nez après le repas donc voilà on
augmente en fait le feu digestif et on
permet d'éviter d'avoir trop de toxines
dans le dans le corps alors je
connaissais le gingjamb le citron ça ça
va encore le sel rose je connaissais pas
c'est quoi sa particularité alors en
fait il est beaucoup plus doux que le
sel lambda qu'on peut trouver en
commerce et il s'accommode vraiment très
bien parce que vous allez voir qu'avec
le citron et la jambe c'est déjà assez
fort donc ce type de sel permet un petit
peu d'adoucir et de pas être trop
prononcé et pourquoi alors ces
ingrédients sont-ils bénéfiques pour
nous voilà qu'on on les prend dans leur
dans leur entièreté que ce soit le le
gingembre le citron le le sel pourquoi
ils vont être bénéfiques pour nous alors
c'est surtout cette convergence des
trois qui est très intéressant parce
qu'en fait le salé l'acide et le piquant
c'est trois saveurs en Ayurvéda qui
aident à booster le métabolisme et à
éviter que les toxines soit trop
importante dans le dans le corps et dans
le système digestif donc c'est très
intéressant de les prendre ensemble mais
on peut aussi les prendre de manière
éparce par exemple un jus de citron avec
de l'eau chaude ça sera tout à fait
aussi une façon de prendre soin de son
système digestif avant les fêtes ou
pendant les fêtes ou juste une infusion
de gingembre c'est tout à fait aussi
possible mais si vous mixez les trois
vous avez encore plus de potentialité et
de puissance alors on va vous laisser
dans notre salon de tv78 préparer
tranquillement ce petit apéritif et bien
sûr mati tout à l'heure on goûtera je
pense que c'est c'est ce qu'on attend
tous oui vous savez très bien vous me
connaissez très bien Grégory à chaque
fois qu'on parle de nourriture ou de
manger moi j'ai toujours hâte de goûter
la
période je je sais que Michel vous aussi
vous aimez bien manger et goûter la
période de Noël c'est aussi l'occasion
de faire davantage de bonnes actions
poupées camion de Pompi ou encore jeux
de société les associations de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline redouble
d'attention pour que les plus démunis
passent un beau réveillon Julien Leroi
nous présente deux association au grand
cœur n'oubliez pas votre petit cadeau de
Noël oui de joyeuses fêtes pour tous à
Montini le Bretonneux la boutique
baliskii accompagne chaque mois 50
familles adressées par des travailleurs
sociaux produits alimentaires ou
d'hygiènes leur sont vendus à 50 % moins
cher que le prix en magasin pour
prolonger cette solidarité un colis
agrémenté d'articles de beauté et de
friandise est offert à chaque
bénéficiaire en cette fin d'année une
action grand cœur aussi pour les plus
jeunes l'association leur distribue des
jeux grâce à un don de la société asmodé
à guillencour l'année dernière nous
avons une famille quand elles ont eu le
colis de Noël et qui avait les jouets
pour les enfants la maman a pleuré parce
qu'elle m'a dit je pourrais au moins
mettre des jouets sous le sapin de Noël
pour des enfants 21e siècle bon voilà
c'est là on se dit on a rempli notre
rôle il y a des puzzles il y a des
jouets pour les enfants desons le Père
Noël n'oublie personne durant les deux
derniers weekends une grande collecte de
jouets était organisée dans les locaux
de l'association plaisiroise plaisir
solidarité poupée peluches ou camion de
pompiers pour le moment près de 80
articles ont été rassemblés grâce à une
dizaine de donateurs l'ensemble sera
remis à 100 enfants du quartier du
valibou à l'issue d'un spectacle de
clown ce 28 décembre on a fait quatre
groupes fille et garçon et de 3 à 6 ans
et de 7 à 10 ans donc on va répartir les
jouets en fonction des trois groupes et
il y aura donc un tirage au sort par
l'enfant on l'appellera en fait et il
tirera au sort un numéro qui
correspondra à un jouet parce que ça
nous a paru difficile parce qu'il y a
des jours qui vont être plus bons que
d'autres ainsi de suite on a tous bah
des enfants qui grandissent et donc il y
a des jouets qui ne servent plus et qui
sont encore en bon état donc autant que
ça serve à d'autres c'est toujours beau
quand les enfants ils découvrent un
cadeau et qu'ils ont les yeux qui voilà
qui sont pleins d'étoiles l'association
plaisir solidarité espère étendre son
action à d'autres quartiers de la
commune l'année prochaine des opérations
à Saint-Quentin en Yveline pour ne
mettre personne de côté le soir de
Noël la question tant redoutter Grégory
est-ce que vous avez fini vos cadeaux de
Noël presque la question qu' presque
presque ouais presque il m'en reste un
ou deux je ne diraiis pas pour
qui moi je fais toujours partie des
retardataires donc c'est en cours vous
les faites le 23 le 24 à peu près oui
Clara vous avez fini vous non pas du
tout du que gabrielattend d'avoir des
idées ce soir peut-être vous pouvez y
aller ensemble peut-être pour choisir
les cadeau mais je crois que Patrice
carmous il a des idées pour nous non
absolument oui al moi vous me posez pas
la question à moi la question mais c'est
pas grave non c'est pas grave moi pour
une fois je suis fier de le dire je l'
fait en avance voilà et franchement
c'est c'est incroyable mais
effectivement alors on me dit que mon
nœud papillon est de travers pardon pour
les téléspectateurs de tv78 alors vous
parliez de ces idées cadeaux qui ve qui
nous sont donné par Patrice carmous des
idées de cadeaux qui peuvent être 100 %
évinoises on le verra tout à l'heure
aussi dans cette émission en tout cas si
vous êtes en panne d'inspiration un bon
livre ça fait toujours plaisir Patrice
carmos est allé justement la rencontre
de l'équipe de la librairie du pavé du
canal c'est à monsign le Bretonneux ils
nous ont sélectionné les libraires
quelques livres à offrir pour Noël
regardez bien je pense que ça peut vous
plaire
Michel bonjour ça va
[Musique]
bien
Laurent Garin depuis depuis le début je
parle de la librairie du canal le vrai
nom c'est le pavé du canal c'est ça tout
à fait le pavé du canal libr du canal on
les aime beaucoup mais ils sont à bas
ils sont tout oui il y a une librie qui
s'appelle aussi li du canal oui c'est le
canal de la Bastille mais ici c'est le
pavé du canal c'est ça parce que le le
fondateur était 68 et les pavés
forcément pour lui c'est une vraie
résonance mais je me su je l'ai reçu
j'ai connu tout à fait alors bonjour
bonjour Patrice comment ça va ça va très
bien bah je suis heureux parce que là on
va parler parler un peu bouffe quoi
bienvenue en cuisine alors j'ai un coup
de cœur je veux absolument vous le
montrer c'est mon coup de cœur de
l'année donc je commence par celui-là je
vais le je vais le donner à Laurent
peut-être est-ce que vous connaissez
Marseille Patrice un peu Marseille
Marseille et en fait c'est c'est assez
rare pour une ville française tout le
monde a un avis sur Marseille qu'on
habite Marseille ou pas on a tous un
avis sur Marseille beaucoup de copains
Marseillais en plus voilà parce que
c'est une ville je pense qui cristallise
beaucoup de choses qui cristallise la
passion les engouments on connait tous
tapis de voilà en même temps Zida et sa
femme voilà
Edmond charlerou voilà
failli me planter là marseillais non non
pas du tout et justement il y a plein de
Parisiens qui aiment Marseille faut pas
voilà donc audelà des clichés le
l'auteur qui s'appelle Ezéchiel zera
vous propose Marseille un jour sans fin
voilà je mot et c'est un c'est un livre
qui est sorti chez achette cuisine et
c'est génial parce qu'en fait il nous
propose un voyage culinaire à Marseille
sur une journée type sur 25h alors 25
pas 24 parce qu'à Marseille on fait
toujours plus que plus que les autres et
en fait c'est 24 petits voyages dans la
la la gastronomie je dirais même la
bouffe à Marseille dans le bon sens du
terme alors on dit la gastronomie c'est
les recettes c'est les c'est les
établissements alors justement c'est en
fait c'est vu sur un grand panorama le
spectre est très large vous allez avoir
des recettes évidemment de la soupe au
pistou par exemple vous allez avoir la
la recette de la Yoli mais au-delà de ça
vous allez avoir aussi des témoignages
des témoignages de cuisinière de
cuisiniers vous allez avoir des des
témoignages de commerce ambulant vous
allez avoir des des témoignages de
serveurs de serveuses et cetera et vous
allez avoir plein de petits reportages
sur des petits des petits aspects qu'on
connaît pas forcément normalement après
on goûte les recettes qui ont été faites
normalement oui fait on vous devez
installer un petit non
c'est prévu oui c'est prévu on n dit pas
plus mais c'est prévu merci beaucoup
merci à
[Musique]
bientôt je sens que vous allez l'acheter
ce livre Michel non oui tout à fait
ouioui c'est parce que ma mère est
d'origine marseillaise donc je descends
souvent à Marseille effectivement ça
m'intéresse ça vous donne envie de
goûter aussi donne goûter aussi oui non
c'est c'est un livre qui qui m'intéresse
particulièrement en tout cas si vous
aussi ça vous intéresse vous pouvez
regarder cette émission en intégralité
sur notre site Internet
tv78 et sur nos réseaux sociaux le pavé
du canal nous propose plein de livres
différents mangas bande dessinée beauard
ou encore livre jeunesse vous avez le
choix et Grégory Canalis est reparti
dans le petit salon au côté de Sophie
benabi qui nous prépare un app apétif
ayurvédique c'est un apéritif
ayurvédique pour et bien bien passer la
la période juste après le repas des
fêtes à base de gingembre de citron de
sel de rose de l'Himalaya on peut aussi
ajouter du miel he c'est ça on peut
agrémenter exactement on peut ajouter du
miel pour adoucir un petit peu le goût
et pour les becs un peu plus sucrés
alors vous les avez préparé on a parlé
tout à l'heure des bienfaits de chaque
ingrédient du gingembre du citron du sel
rose de l'Himalaya est-ce que le fait de
les associer ça va décupler les les
effets bénéfiques justement oui parce
qu'en fait en fait le sel va booster la
salivation ce qui va entretenir la
digestion va l'amorcer le citron c'est
un détoxifiant assez puissant même titre
que le gingembre et le fait de les
associer ensemble permet d'avoir ce ce
côté un peu enfin allumer le feu en
quelque sorte intérieur et détox aussi
derrière pour bien métaboliser le plat
donc c'est bien les associer ensemble
alors cet apéritif vous l'avez préparé
là pendant nos différents Magneto et en
fait finalement vous l'avez terminé donc
c'est très rapide finalement à faire
ultra rapide comment vous l'avez préparé
expliquez-nous alors hyper simple en
fait vous coupez des petites rondelles
assez fines de gingembre vous pouvez
aussi avoir la version râpée si on
préfère avoir le goût râpé du gingembre
et vous mettez dessus en fait du jus de
citron donc juste un petit peu pour que
ça recouvre la la lame de la lamelle de
gingembre et vous ajoutez dessus une
petite pincée de sel et puis vous le
mangez comme ça en fait 30 minutes avant
de prendre votre repas de Noël donc ça
vous a pris à peu près 5 minutes monre
en main oh même pas 2 minutes ultra
rapide et tous ces ingrédients se les
procurent facilement alors oui vous
pouvez les acheter alors c'est mieux de
de prendre en magasin bio si vous pouvez
pour éviter d'avoir bien sûr les
pesticides du dans le gingembre et dans
le citron sinon dans un mag enfin en
grande surface vous pouvez tout à fait
en trouver le sel de l'Himalaya c'est
plutôt en magasin biologique c'est très
difficile à trouver en grande surface ou
alors sur Internet est-ce que c'est a
des prix abordables qu'on les trouve le
sel de l'Himalaya il est très abordable
c'est vraiment très peu cher pour 200 g
vous vous payez à peu près 3 € donc
c'est vraiment très peu et vous les
conseillez de de le consommer quand
après le repas juste après un jour après
alors vraiment avant le repas avant
c'est l'apéritif qui est avant le repas
avant de prendre l'entrée par exemple
vous mangez ça 30 minutes avant il faut
bien 30 minutes pour que la combuston se
mette un petit peu en place au niveau du
système digestif ou alors on peut le
prendre aussi après le repas pareil 30
minutes après le repas donc c'est soit
on va dire pour préparer le repas soit
juste après on va dire pour le
désamorcer si je puux dire et une fois
que c'est préparé est-ce qu'il faut le
consommer à la minute est-ce qu'il faut
le consommer assez rapidement vous
pouvez le laisser un petit peu macérer
pour que le jus de citron avec le sel et
le gingembre travaille ensemble donc
vous pouvez le laisser reposer par
exemple là je je l'aurais fait donc pour
30 minutes enfin 30 minutes après manger
ça aurait été parfait donc je peux le
faire un petit peu en avance comme ça
prend pas de temps on peut aussi le
faire à la dernière minute si on préfère
on peut le consommer tout de suite du
coup on peut le consommer tout de suite
je vous laisse retirer votre micro on va
aller rejoindre les autres en plateau
pour leur faire goûter je vais vous
filer un petit coup de main
hop on a hâte de goûter ça allez-y et
vous pouvez vous mettre à côté de
Gabriel sur le plateau et on va bah
distribuer à chacun sa petite bouchée
voi Mathilde merci beauoup merci faire
goûter également à George schmi voi
merci
beaucoup ah oui une cure et du coup il
m' reste pour moi oui et on mange
commeci alors oui est-ce qu'on s'attend
c'est ça manger tout ça en même temps
beaucoup ouis ça va être avoir un peu de
feu dans la bouche d'accord c'est très
pratique pour présenter après ce que
j'allais dire ça permet de mieux jouer
alors ok on pour jouer de la F de pain
ouais ah oui c'est fort c'est fort c'est
le but je vais devenir
tout ah
oui fa pas en manger trop un petit peu
j'ai tout manger voilà mais je pense que
du coup le
gingembreoui ça détoxifie
bien petite réaction Clara quand vous
aurez récupéré votre voix vous confirmez
le piquant j'ai l'impression votre tête
le conf rouge les ye qui pique un peu
rouge réchauffé un petit peu on sent la
détox tout de suite là on la sent là
pour le coup du coup là en so on va
préparer un peu notre digestion du repas
de ce soir déjà B tout à fait il faut
manger dans les dem c'est mieux c'est
mieux d'accord ok oui sinon le feu va
trop brûler on a compris ce qu'il faut
faire après l'émission ben merci
beaucoup en tout cas Sophie benavi pour
cette dégustation
pimentée que serait Noël sans cadeau
Clara vous nous proposer quelques idées
de cadeau 100 % ivelinois on commence
avec des savons artiano et écologique
élaboré à carrière souspoissie oui c'est
bain d'étoil fondé par Magalie Cochet
Blin qui propose ses savons naturels
éthiques et écoresponsables ils sont
entièrement produits à carrière spoissie
à partir d'ingrédients issus de
l'agriculture biologique fabriqué moulé
et découpé à la main elle utilise une
méthode ancestrale de la saponisation à
froid chaque année l'artisane produit
près de 4000 savons vous pouvez les
retrouver dans sa boutique situé à
poissie vous aurez le choix entre les
savons pour le corps pour le visage mais
aussi pour les cheveux parce que oui
bain d'étoile fabrique ces shampoings
solides ils conviennent à tous les types
de peau et à tous les types de cheveux
et ils sont disponibles à partir de 5 €.
vous les connaissez bien Gabriel c'est
ça oui j'avais tourné un reportage avec
magalco chez Blin et oui tout est fait
maison donc un beau cadeau y noir h et
donc si vous souhaitez aller plus loin
bain d'étoile propose aussi des savons
tout usage à l'huile de coco il utilise
il s'utilise pardon pour laver la
vaisselle le linge ou pour les
différentes surfaces de la maison compte
à partir de 2,50 € pour ce produits pour
les plus indécis ne vous inquiétez pas
j'ai aussi pensé à vous la boutique
propose aussi des coffrets euh de savon
à partir de 18 €. et alors pour le
prochain cadeau Clara vous nous emmenez
au musée de la toile de joui à joui en
Josas et plus précisément dans sa
boutique qui propose des créations
originales inspirées de motifs de la
toile de joui fabriqué par des artisans
locaux vous pourrez y trouver toutes
sortes de produits décoration
d'intérieur vêtements pour femmes et
hommes papéterie accessoires ou encore
art de la table et il y en a pour tous
les goûts et pour tous les prix comptez
5,90 € pour un assortiment de ces postal
14,50 € pour un carnet ou encore 35 €
pour une bougie et son pochon la
boutique est ouverte du mardi au
dimanche aux heures d'ouverture du musée
mais si vous souhaitez il existe
également une boutique en ligne c'est
très à la mode la toile de jou
apparemment oui c'est vrai très à la mod
c'est vrai que les grands créateurs s'en
inspirent régulièrement pour leur
nouvelle collection oui un cadeau
original et à la mode du
coupinois toutes les cases et alors pour
la la dernière idée de cadeau Clara vous
nous emmenez aux EOS safari de toiri oui
si vous cherchez un cadeau assez
original et qui fera plaisir à coup sûr
je vous propose d'offrir un passe annuel
pour le zoau toiri une expérience
immersive en plein cœur de la Faun et de
la flore en illimité et sans restriction
pendant un an vous pourrez traverser le
safari en voiture pour observer les
animaux du parc dans un espace ouvert si
vous préférez une rencontre plus intime
avec ces animaux il est aussi possible
d'explorer le parc à pied vous pourrez y
croiser 750 animaux et 110 espèces
différentes euh le passe annuel est à 62
€ pour les adultes et à 45 € pour les
enfants âgés de 3 à 11 ans et pour
prolonger l'expérience il est maintenant
possible aussi d'offrir une nuit au plus
près des animaux oui depuis le 20
octobre dernier le zoo safari de toiri
propose désormais cinq lodges euh de
luxe pour vivre au rythme des éléphants
compter 680 € la nuit pour deux
personnes le tarif comprend de jour
d'entrée au parc les repas une visite
privative de la maison des éléphants
ainsi qu'un un entraînement médical
pour les plus aventurés vous pouvez
aussi choisir de dormir à côté des ours
et des loups dans des tanières en pleine
nature compté à partir de 150 € la nuit
par personne merci Clara vous avez
rempli le Paris vous avez tenu le Paris
des idées de cadeau 100 % évinoise dans
quelques instants avec vous Michel on
verra aussi que ces idées 100% Vinois
peuvent se mettre directement sur la
table à déguster à Noël tout à fait à
Noël et pour les fêtes de fin d'année
mais juste avant cela pris mon souffle
après le voilà on récupère notre souffle
après cet apéritif bravo à Clara pour
pour cette chronique c'était loin d'être
facile P on continua de parler avec vous
he Sophie d'ayour Veda dans dans un
instant dans le 78 mais avance la
nouveau détour par la commune de
Saint-Germain au lait on va retrouver de
nouveau sur place Régine ralèche voilà
on voit qu'il fait froid je sais qu'il y
a une fine pluie aussi qui tombe du côté
du village de Noël vous vous trouvez en
compagnie de Julien Leroi sur place dans
ce village de Noël qui est ouvert à
Saint-Germain en lait jusqu'au 31
décembre exactement et vous l'avez dit
hein moi je me trouve au stand des îles
justement pour retrouver un peu de
chaleur par ce temps froid et je me
retrouve en présence d'iveliz qui tient
une entreprise au padalia alors yel
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter un
peu vos spécialités bah bonsoir tout le
monde et voilà bonjour à tous et
bienvenue donc oui on est producteur de
spiritueux et traiteur événementiel donc
ce soir je vous présente du coup nos
fameux spiritu donc vous avez le ponche
passion et le fameux ponche citron vert
voilà pour les fêtes vous avez aussi les
différents cocktails tels que le
planteur la Pinacolada la Dalia aussi
qui sont des cocktails voilà phare de
chez nous on fait aussi des cocktails
sans alcool et vous avez aussi le vin
chaud et le rum chaud qui voilà qui sont
à déguster chez nous et à consommer sur
place vous avez aussi du coup le
chocolat antillaet voilà qui est typique
chez nous aussi donc on le présente
aussi ce soir et vous avez aussi les
beignets de banane planttin que vous
pouvez retrouver aussi les acrases Moru
je suis désolée on en a a plus parce que
bon voilà à chaque fois c'est vraiment
voilà la folie pour les akras donc je
suis désolée de pas pouvoir vous les
présenter ce soir voilà rupture ah oui
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de succès en
tout cas moi les beignet de banane il me
donnent envie je peux goûter oui oui
vous pouvez goûter avec grand plaisir
voilà vous voyez hein Grégorie et
Mathilde moi je me régale ici tout est
génial j'ai quand même une dernière
question parce que vous aviez discuter
justement du rom chaud nous on on a
l'habitude du vin chaud c'est assez
atypique le romchaud c'est quelque chose
qu'on retrouve pas tout le temps alors
oui en effet le romcho existe déjà
depuis très longtemps mais du coup on le
présente ici sur on le trouve rarement
mais on le présente en tout cas ici sur
le village de Noël de Saint-Germain en
lait et aussi à conflan saint-onorine on
peut retrouver bien sûr tous nos
produits voilà donc on fait le fameux
rom show et à la différence bien sûr
c'est un peu le même concept mais du
coup c'est sur des plutôt des couleurs
exotique voilà merci beaucoup evel voilà
si vous aussi vous avez envie d'y goûter
B tout tout se passe ici au village de
Noël à Saint-Germain au lait et c'est
jusqu'au 31 décembre merci Régine avec
Julien le roi au moyen technique on va
vous laisser rentrer tranquillement
c'est qu'il fait froid n'hésitez pas
d'ailleurs bon appétit ouais n'hésitez
pas à venir en plateau si l'émission
n'est pas encore terminer quand vous
arriverez dans les locaux de tv78 pour
goûter le gingembre après la
banane alors je vous en parlais en début
d'émission j'espère que vous connaissez
les champs de Noël sur le bout des
doigts je sais que cl vous êtes très
forte en blind test George Schmith vous
êtes un professionnel de la flûte de Pan
vous avez 11 disque d'or vous avez
travaillé avec Eno moricon pour le
cinéma la publicité également Cosma
moricon j'en Pass vous avez donné des
concerts dans le monde entier pas monde
entier mais fait presque les C
continents quand même les C continents
ou est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire une
petite démonstration en direct comme ça
oh ben
oui tiens euh on va essayer de deviner
on va essayer de devinerce c'est pas
Noël
c'est il moricon
ah mission il l'avait en régie il en rég
ce qui appartient à César vous avez le
droit de jouer aussi he ce
je vous propose qu'on continue avec un
un blind test mais plutôt sur les sur
les champs de Noël est-ce qu'on fait des
teams ou c'est le premier qui répond je
pense qu'on peut faire le premier qui
répond allez c'est parfait Clara va
gagner à chaque fois là Noël donc vous
juste vous avez changé de flutes de Pan
vous en avez pris une plus
grand parce que je fabrique j'ai
l'avantage de fabriquer toutes mes
floutes de Pan qui sont accordable comme
je fais beaucoup de concerts en Église
Flut de Pan et org essentiellement aucun
org en France est accordé exactement
pareil normalement c'est diapason 440
maintenant enfin c'est la la fréquence
mais les anciens orges de 1700 1800 il
sont un ton en dessous souvent alors
j'ai eu l'idée de remplacer la cire
d'abeille qu'on utilisait
traditionnellement par des pistons qui
fait dans chaque tube j'ai mis voyez il
y a une tige filtée avec cette tige
filtée j'ai des pistons en liège avec un
écrou qui est serti à à la base de
chaque piston qui permet de descendre
monter les les pistons alors en Alsace
les orges sont toujours très bas alors
je descends les je m'accorde en fonction
de et ça c'est un gain de temps
considérable et je c'est vrai je gagne
beaucoup de
temps pour accorder mes flutes ce soit
pour la publicité pour le cinéma pas
allez-y allez-y allez-y allez-y on vous
écoute
Noël
alors c'est une
publicité ex exactement bien joué à
Patrick JAC
[Musique]
de
non j'ai fait toutes les séries
nescaféta
chambours caprice des dieux aussi je me
souviens plus alors souvent je rentre en
studio on met la partition sous les yeux
et puis euh lorsque ben je vais passer
des fois une demi journée enregistrer
faut que ça tombe pile en fonction de
l'image et puis dès que je sors du
studio j'ai souvent oublié mais puis ça
quand je l'entends des fois ça peut être
vous joué tellement au final ben j'ai
énormément un moment où parce que
lorsquil av besoin de son réel de flit
de P maintenant c'est fait avec des
synthétiseur ça pas tout à fait le même
son bon mais c'est pas grave et comme
c'est une émission spéciale Noël est-ce
que vous pouvez nous faire au MO
Noë oui oui
[Musique]
euh
alors est-ce qu'on a la réponse en fait
vous la réponse je pense pas la réponse
c'est un ch de Noël allemand
Frich ou jeavais pas reconnu comme
ça en tout cas ça a pas l'air si simple
que ça on voit que vous avez bien la
technique quand même il y a des petits
jour mais savez quand j'ai obligé j'ai
pas le choix et vous avez commencé à
quel âge alors j'avais une vingtaine
d'années j'ai découvert la flutete de
Pan à travers le folklore d'Amérique du
Sud d'Europe centrale et puis j'ai eu
l'idée d'abord hein de décorer ma
chambre mais vraiment peu de temps après
je me suis dit pourquoi est-ce que j'en
jouerais pas et puis voilà je jouais la
fute à B fut traversière avant et j'ai
abandonné vraiment tous les autres
instruments et vous avez appris seul ou
vous êtes for ou j'aiis pas le choix
j'ai appris seul j'ai un peu appris avec
zampfir j' enfire le le bon et euh
j'étais devenu un concurrent direct
dommage enfin c'est c'est pas vraiment
le cas mais bon je voulez plus me
recevoir l'élève a dépassé le
maître non non j'ai pas cette prétention
et alors apparemment vous pouvez aussi
imiter le bruit d'une flute avec
seulement vos mains est-ce que vous
pouvez nous montrer seulement vos mains
oui mais pour ça je pris le MI ah
[Musique]
pardon
et cel voulait
essayer super
impressionn on a tous enfin je pense la
plupart d'entre nous on a lorsqu'on
était gamin on a essayé de faire imiter
oui la chouette moi j'ai jamais réussi
voilà et je me suis rendu compte qu' en
modulant on essayé en modulant on peut
obtenir des sons différents et j'ai
quasiment de octaves comme ça mais ça se
travaille aussi c'est pareil mais voilà
c'est alors j'ai j'ai fait quand j'étais
gamin j'ai fait j'étais passionné
partout l'ornitologie j'ai fait beaucoup
de je voulais être ornitologue quand
j'étais gamin
[Musique]
ouais vous avez de multiples talents en
fait
voilà et alors juste pourquoi est-ce
qu'on appelle ça la flute de pan alors
c'est parce que c'est d'après la
mythologie greque c'est le dieu Pan qui
poursuivait les nymphes syyrinx et puis
un jour elle s'est enfuie prise de
frayeur et elle s'est transformée en
roseau alors le diopant a pris ses
roseaux les a attrapé enfin les a
découpés et en différentes longueurs
comme ceci et il a assemblé donc ces
tubes s'est aperçu en soufflant dans
chacun des tuyaux que l'on pouvit faire
descendes doncon a appelé depuis cet
instrument une flute de pain au syrinx
en hommage à celle qui avait été coupé
en petits morceau voilà c'est pourquoi
l'origine du mot panique vient du grec
pan panique Panicos
ok vous connaissez l'histoire en plateau
pas du tout pas du tout voilà on en
apprend les jour merci beaucoup moi j'ai
fait beaucoup de parce que je suis agréé
par l'Éducation nationale j'ai fait
beaucoup de spectacles jeune public et
c'est vraiment ça me vraiment ça me fait
énormément plaisir de retrouver à
travers toute la France hein quand je
vais jouer euh de retrouver des enfants
adultes maintenant qui viennent avec
leurs enfants me disant vous êtes venus
dans mon collège ou dans mon école et ça
ça fait vraiment plaisir quoi et
d'ailleurs si on veut vous voir en
concert ce sera début janvier dans le
Hain du côté de mouse j'ai pas dans les
ivelines ce sera quand les prochaines
dates le 2 mars à Saint-Germain ENL j'ai
c'est un gros concert
c'est au profit des des enfants et des
femmes battues c'est organisé par le
Lyon club des de
Saint-Germain la grande église juste en
face du châteauement là où était Régine
tout à
l'heure merci beaucoup encore vous
restez avec nous puisqu'on va parler de
produits yvelinois qu'on peut mettre à
notre table de Noël on parlait tout à
l'heure avec Clara des des idées de
cadeaux 100 % yvelinoise et bien pour
célébrer les fêtes de fin d'année on
peut le faire aussi avec des produits
gastronomiques yvelinois Michel c'est
tout à fait possible oui tout à fait on
peut dire qu'on peut trouver quelques
pépites dans le département des ivines
on va commencer par une spécialité salée
le célèbre pâté de Oudan mise au point
au 19e siècle il a ses codes de
fabrication il est même encadré par une
confrériie gastronomique le pâté de
houdans c'est avant tout un pâté en
croûte à base de poule de houdans une
volaille ancienne à Crète sa farce est
également composée d'une mousse de fois
de volaille de champignon le tout dans
une pâte brisée le pâté de houdans est
un met surprenant et idéal à mettre sur
votre table moi j'en j'en saliv rien d'y
penser je crois que vous Grégory vous
avez goûé connais bien et j'ai pu suivre
cette année le le concours annuel qui
récompense le meilleur pâté de haudans
il y a il y a tout un un rituel autour
de ce pâté et une tradition qui est
perpétué à auents et c'est bon vous
l'avez goûté aussi c'est très bon c'est
très bon j'ai goûté le pâté qui a
remporté le concours cette année il
était vraiment très très bon vous le
conseillez pour Noël bien sûr on
continue avec du salé Michel oui c'est
mon coup de cœur dans cette sélection au
cœur de la vallée de la Vau couleur dans
les zvelines une pisculture est
installée depuis 1896 on pu on peut y
acheter de la truite arc-en-ciel fario
ou jaune elles sont élevées sur place
dans des bassins le nourrissage et
manuel et garanti sans OGM c'est bon et
c'est bio pour des saveurs plus prononcé
préférez les fumer au bois de être dans
ce four traditionnel compte 3 € pièces
pour une truite fraîche de 250 g ou 4,80
€ pour une truite fumée de 150 g alors
pour découvrir le goût authentique de ce
produit viinois haut de gamme
rendez-vous dans la boutique sur place
ça a l'air aussi appétissant très
appétissant oui effectivement on passe
maintenant au sucré vous allez parler
d'une petite gourmandise Michel alors je
sais que vous adorez ce pain d'épic
Mathilde c'est un pain d'épic de la
marque ivinoise les deux gourmands une
marque créée il y a 11 ans par deux amis
leurs produits sont composés de produits
issus du territoire francilien ils
proposent des biscuits pour l'apéritif
mais aussi du pain d'épic nature c'est
lui qui nous intéresse ces pains d'épic
sont composés à 50 % de miel de forêt
issu de massif désimin et du gaâtiner
dans le centre val-deloire dedans vous
retrouverez également de la farine de
seggle de blé du beurre frais de la
laterie d'ini des œufs élevés en plein
air et bien sûr la fameuse cannelle il y
a également une recette secrète pour
mélanger ce pain d'épic mais on ne vous
en dira pas plus plus il fera sensation
le jour de Noël j'en suis sûr et
Mathilde
ças très très B alors pour accompagner
tout ça parce que nous avez parlé
d'aliments nous propos aussi quelques
boissons et et d'abord une boisson
alcoolisée oui je vous propose de
découvrir une bouteille de vin 100ans%
yvelinoise une bouteille qui vient du
domaine de la bouche du roi dans la
petite commune de Davron dans la plaine
de Versailles le le vignoble a été créé
en en 2017 ce vin s'exporte aujourd'hui
dans toute la France c'est un clin d'œil
au roi de France et au passéiticol de la
région une région investie par les
someliers au 16e siècle sur 26 hectares
et 19 parcelles le domaine propose une
collection de spages ancien et six grand
spages français avis aux amateurs au
passionnés de vin le prix moyen pour une
bouteille est de 27 € alors moi je l'ai
goûté il est quand même assez prometteur
ce vin il est encore tout jeune mais il
est prometteur c'est assez insolite vous
saviez Sophie George qui avait du vin
yvelinois alors là pas du tout non à une
quinzaine de minutes de nos studios à de
je prendrai Volter les adresses don vous
inquiétez pas que ça consomm avec
modération alors pour ceux qui ne
consomment pas d'alcool justement vous
proposez aussi une limonade oui à cher
la brasserie ecooresonsable respecte
continue son expansion ouverte depuis
fin 2020 la structure qui produit cette
année près de 300 heectolites de bière
vient de lancer sa limonade les deux
passionnés de bière se sont lancés cette
année dans une boisson sans alcool ils
ont créé leur limonade ils
commercialisent ce nouveau produits dans
leur local les salles de spectacles les
épiceries fines ou les cinémas des
environs elle est vendu un peu plus de
2,50 € en fonction des goûts je l'ai
goûté c'est très bon également les goûts
sont un peu surprenants j'ai goûté le
lichi framboise et menthe citron vert
c'était pas mal ben merci beaucoup
Michel pour toutes ces idées 100
% pour se rafraîchir après
leadress quand on prend le
par meilleur quand on quand on goûte le
deème le
deè ou oui s Habu ah d'accord just plus
justement on vous donnera toutes les
bonnes adresses aussi fait pour ça le 78
c'est de susciter des rencontres vous
apprendre des choses alors pour digérer
tous ces met on le disait tout à l'heure
on a commencé à vous parler de
l'Ayurveda est-ce que Gabriel vous
pouvez tourner le micro légèrement vers
notre invité Sophie benami on le
rappelle qui est donc thérapeute en
Ayurveda installé à guancour alors on a
commencé à à présenter tout à l'heure
cette médecine traditionnelle indienne
l'objectif c'est d'harmoniser le corps
et l'esprit pour le bien-être du corps
humain c'est ça exactement d'harmoniser
le corps l'esprit le mental pour que
tout fonctionne de concert et qu'on soit
bien dans ses baskets concrètement ça va
nous aider en quoi l'Ayurveda pour ces
fêtes de fin d'année alors ça va aider à
composer les repas de manière on va dire
intelligente dans le sens éviter de trop
obstruer son corps donc avec des choses
mais vraiment hyper simples et que tout
à chacun peut faire donc par exemple
éviter de boire froid à table parce que
le fait de boire froid en fait vous
allez éteindre votre feu digestif et
vous allez vous sentir lourd
donc on évite de mettre des glaçons dans
son verre on évite de boire des par
exemple un champagne trop trop froid
donc c'est quoi le mieux c'est
température ambiante estce qu'on peut
boire chaud ex on peut boire chaud si on
le souhaite alors là c'est idéal donc
pendant le repas par exemple ou avant
avec une petite infusion d'épic par
exemple c'est très bien ou alors juste à
température ambiante ça sera parfait
mais jamais glacé et on évite les
glaçons de de préférence ensuite ça va
être utiliser les épices c'est ça on va
les parsemer sur nos aliments
ce soit notre fois gras les viandes les
poissons d épic alors en fait chaque
aliment va avoir des affinetés avec des
épices particulières donc là pour
prendre un exemple ça peut être la crème
glacée les bûches de voilà de de Noël
donc là les épices qui vont être très
intéressante pour les digérer ça va être
la cannelle qui va aider à digérer le
lactose des produits laitiers on va
avoir le safran la noix de muscade le
gingembre qu'on a vu tout à l'heure qui
peut énormément aider aussi et le la
cardamom et après pour le fromage par ex
par exemple si vous servez du fromage à
table vous pouvez aussi mettre par
exemple des graines de cumin qu'on
retrouve dans le fameux goudda au cumin
bon qui est peut-être un peu moins sympa
pour Noël mais qui est très intéressant
d'un point de vue ayurvidique ou alors
des graines de fenouil en fait tout ce
qui va être un peu carminatif qui va
aider à à diminuer tout ce qui est
ballonnement va pouvoir aider à digérer
les choses lourdes donc j'ai cité la
crème glacée mais il y a aussi la viande
la viande donc la viande alors là c'est
peut-être un peu plus commun mais tout
ce qui va être ail romarin la sariette
le thint ça ça va aider ça ça va aider
la digestion tout ce qui est Aromat et
épices aide à la digestion et de
préférence très bien digérer son
repas déguste encore ce petit
effectivement dis à l'instant le
deuxième passe mieux le deè passe mieux
oui parce que le palais est beaucoup
plus habitué en fait et PE
anesthés alors il y a un autre conseil
qui semble simple quand quand je l'ai lu
c'est de faire une petite marche juste
après le le repasou exactement on y
pense pas forcément mais ça ça peut être
aussi pour le quotidien c'est de prendre
l'habitude d'aller marcher juste 15 à 20
minutes donc là par exemple si vous
faites Noël vous fêtez Noël à midi vous
prévoyez d'aller faire une petite balade
avec vos convives et vous allez vous
aérer et ça permet en fait d'entretenir
les mouvements du péristaltisme et donc
d'aider à bien digérer donc c'est
vraiment très simple mais hyper effic
combi temps environ il faut marcher
entre 15 à 20 minutes c'est le minimum
c'est déjà efficace après si vous faites
une heure c'est très bien et après avoir
mangé bien sûr et après avoir mangé
exactement oui oui c'est pour aider à la
dig balade digestive tout à fait
dominicale la plupart du temps et alors
il peut arriver que ces repas des fêtes
soient arrosé alors on rappelle l'alcool
est à consommer avec modération mais
justement pour prévenir la gueule de
bois pour mieux la la digérer en quelque
sorte quel quels sont les les aliments
quels sont les conseils que vous pouvez
donner alors déjà ça va être d'éviter de
manger trop lourd pour pas trop
congestionner le foie le système
digestif le pancréas qui déjà travaille
beaucoup par la digestion de l'alcool
donc si vous pouvez vous évitz d'ajouter
euh du chocolat de reboire de l'alcool
derrière de manger trop carnet donc trop
de viande par exemple au lendemain de
fête donc manger très léger des
bouillons des soupes des assiettes de
légumes et puis il y a une petite astuce
c'est de prendre une banane de l'écraser
et euh de mettre dedans du romarin on
peut y ajouter du curcuma et du poivre
et ça en fait ça va éviter qu'on perte
trop de potassium euh avec l'alcool en
fait qui fait fuiter le potassium et qui
donne des mauxs de tête euh et qui
assèche aussi donc ça permet aussi de
réhydrater un un petit peu et de et
d'éviter enfin de soutenir un peu
l'activité du foie qui est un peu mise à
mal par l'alcool avec le Romar j'ai lu
que le gingembre aussi avait un rôle
bénéfique finalement c'est l'ingrédient
miracle pendant ces c'est un peu
l'ingrédient miracle antitoxine qui
qu'on peut utiliser vraiment en fait en
au début du repas pendant le repas et
même après le repas si on l'a asses faê
c'est tout gagné alors si on veut aller
plus loin sur
l'Ayurveda vous avez beaucoup écrit sur
le sujet il y a notamment ce livre qui
s'appelle le grand livre de
l'alimentation ayurvédique ça a été
publié i en 2021 aux éditions Le Duc
dedans on trouve en somme tout un tas de
conseils des recettes aussi alors on
trouve des recettes tout ce qui est
lecture en fait de l'alimentation
ayurvédique parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses à savoir et à connaître et en
fait au final c'est très abordable pour
pour tout le monde donc la cartographie
des aliments comment on fait une détox
ayurvédique comment on compose un plat
ayurvédique pour la famille c'est très
voilà c'est très pratico pratique pour
le quotidien et bien merci d'être venu
en plateau Sophie bienam on précise
d'ailleurs que c'est une reconversion ça
a été un peu une passion laurveda pour
vous oui un coup de foudre un coup de
foudre une rencontre en fait et
effectivement avant j'étais ingénieure
informatique et j'ai tout quitté pour
pour l'Ayurveda et si on veut aller plus
loin donc je disais il y a ce livre il y
a aussi vos réseaux sociaux il y a un
compte qui s'appelle Les Aventures
vertes de Sophie Instagram TikTok
Facebook et également YouTube on peut
retrouver des petits conseils au jour le
jour sur ce compte Instagram et sur les
autres comptes plus de 40000 abonnés he
sur Instagram sur Instagram sur YouTube
sur TikTok et sur Facebook 40000 et une
personne maintenant très préc précis en
direct on aime la la précision merci
beaucoup Michel merci Sophie merci
beaucoup Sophie benabi pour tous ces
conseils moi je vous propose de
poursuivre avec une idée de sortie à
faire pendant les vacances de Noël si
vous avez le temps depuis le mois
d'octobre une quiz room a ouvert ses
portes dans le centre commercial Sky
West à Montini le Bretonneux mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'une quiz room c'est un
endroit où vous pouvez défier vos amis
ou votre famille autour de questions de
culture générale le tout comme sur un
véritable plateau télé cinéma sport
blind test il y en a pour tous les goûts
vraiment et chez tv78 on a décidé
également de se défier je vous propose
de
regarder aujourd'hui on vous emmène à la
découverte de la quiz room de
Saint-Quentin en yeline le principe
blind test et quiz pour faire comme à la
télé et on va se défier Clara toutes les
deux on serait aussi avec d'autres
journalistes de la rédaction de tv78 on
sera avec Grégory canalé et Michel
[Musique]
elmidoro ici vous allez répondre à des
questions pas de surprise jusque là mais
vous allez avoir des jokers pour vous
aider à gagner le meilleur c'est que
vous puissiez bloquer vos
adversaires
[Rires]
allez c'est parti que le meilleur
gagne bonjour tout le monde c'est bon je
suis là on va pouvoir
[Musique]
commencer
[Applaudissements]
vous faites des profil joueurs ici donc
c'est pour ça que votre expérience elle
est 100 % personnalisée en gr cha fois
que vous venez c'est jamais les mêmes
questions c'est des thèmes différents
parce que en fait ce sera en fonction de
votre âge et de vos centres d'intérêt du
sport loisir vie
quotidienne pas mal de choix dans
combien d'états des États-Unis
pratiquet-on encore la peine de
[Musique]
mort
oh
non j'ai hésité j'ai hésité en plus pour
vous aider gagner voilà on met en place
des jokers pourz voler les points de vos
adversaires pouvez doubler les vôtres à
chaque question et pouz aussi bloquer
aussi ces adversaire là avant qu'il
puisse répondre et ça c'est
fun plus
tout du coup deux parties qui durent
chacune une demi-heure et du coup c'est
pour ça qu'on est à partir de 22 € par
personne donc à partir de 7 personnes
vous êtes à 22 € et entre 4 et 6 vous
êtes à 25
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais il a
[Musique]
5ou
c'est Michael Michel le chef le maestro
[Musique]
oui elle m'a bloqué
gagé ça y est on a terminé les deux
parties on s'est super bien amusé on a
passé un super moment vraiment bravo
Clara pour ta victoire merci merci c'est
avec plaisir alors si vous aussi vous
voulez tester la quiz room à
SaintQuentin en Eveline vous pouvez
venir de 4 à 18 joueurs et vous
retrouverez toutes les informations
nécessaires en bas de votre
[Musique]
écran ça va Grégory vous avez bien vous
bien remis j'ai passé un excellent
moment non non je l'ai bien vécu cette
expérience non ça été dur sur le moment
mais au final on a on a bien rigolé on a
passé un bon moment et je précise que
personne n'a été blessé pendant le
tournage je tiens à le direû merci de le
préciser alors Gabriel vous avez
d'autres idées de sortie à nous proposer
pour les vacances de Noël on commence
par quoi et bien je vous emmène célébrer
Noël dans nos monuments yvelinois vous
ne risquez pas de perdre des points
cette fois Grégory pas de souci à
l'occasion des fêtes de fin d'année
l'événement compte et histoire proposé
par le Centre des monuments nationaux
revient au programme spectacle visite
animation dans les ivelines trois
monuments sont concernés le château de
maison à maison la fite propose à ses
visiteurs inclu dos géant accompagné de
spectacle de son côté le Château de
Rambouillet célèbre le nouvel an en
compte et en musique àoisici c'est la
Villa Savoie qui se transforme en boîte
à jeu pour l'occasion pour en savoir
plus sur le programme détaillé
rendez-vous sur le site internet
monument-nationaux.fr à 50 an ieline
souffle aussi un air de Noël puisque le
musée de la ville qui aller à Montini le
Bretonneux s'illumine pour les fêtes oui
pour les vacances de Noël le réseau des
médiathèques et le musée de la ville ont
concocté un programme festif le thème
cette année la lumière en lien avec
l'exposition actuelle du musée de la
ville les allumés du design alors vous
pourrez créer vos propres lampions et
photofor de Noël ça peut donner des
idées de cadeaux et et de quoi illuminer
certainement aussi vos tables pour les
fêtes tout ça sur un air de Noël en plus
ne voilà pour donner un air de Noël a un
petit truc et alors si on veut aussi
compléter sa décoration pour Noël
Gabriel il y a des ateliers créatifs qui
sont proposés pendant les vacances au
musée Maurice Denis oui cette fois ça se
passe au Musée départemental de
Saint-Germain au lait qui propose de
redécouvrir le musée et son exposition
Maurice Denis les chemins de la nature
jusqu'au 5 janvier des ateliers sont
proposés au cours de la visite alors
parmi eux vous l'avez dit création de
carte de vœux art décoratif ou encore
dessin certains ateliers sont
accessibles dès 4 ans sur réservation un
bon moyen de mêler la culture et les
loisirs créatifs celle-ci je l'avais
reconnu vous avez un petit TER de
station d' oui c'était dou si vous avez
un petit TER de station d'hiver vous
pouvez le faire maintenant parce que on
va changer de décor à mant la jolie la
commune justement se transforme en une
station de sport
d'hiver ou oui tout à fait Grégory
patinoir qu sur glace curling ou encore
snowpk et mur d'escalade de glace tout
ça ça se passe dans les ivelines c'est
ce que propose le village sport d'hiver
de Mantel jolie jusqu'au 6 janvier
au-delà des sports d'hiver c'est toute
l'ambiance de Noël qui j'étais pas prête
à l'arrêt c'est inédit vos idées de
sorties avec de la flute de
P Noël donc qui s'installe sur le
village au programme également des
champs de Noël une parade ou encore un
spectacle lumineux c'est l'ambiance
d'une véritable station de ski et on
termine vos idées sorti Gabriel avec un
spectacle féérique au château de
Versailles oui à l'occasion des fêtes de
fin d'année le château de Versailles
propose une plongée dans l'atmosphère
baroque du château au travers d'une
visite spectacle du salon d'Hercule à la
chambre de la reine en passant par la
Galerie des Glaces vous suivrez
comédiens danseur et chanteur pour un
show féérique une immersion dans le
versaill baroque de l'époque et ces
soirées d'exception on regarde un
extrait
et vous l'avez vu sur les images le Père
Noël du château aussi et de la partie un
père Noël h style baroque bien
évidemment il est partout merci beaucoup
Gabriel bravo en tout cas d'avoir gardé
votre
concentration pendant ces idées de
sortie estce qu'autour de la table il y
a des idées qui vous intéressent estce
que vous av qu'est-ce que vous avez
prévu de faire pendant les fêtes Sophie
quelque chose d'assez d'assez simple en
famille mais c'est vrai que le château
de versa ça me dit bien beau spectacle
ça m're ouais à réservver quand même oui
je pense qu'il vaoir du monde Clara elle
est d'accord j'ai l'impression ouais
ouais ça a l'air vachement chouette
franchement pourquoi pas et en face
château de versaill et pourquoi pas
aussi le zo Toir vous m'avez donné envie
tout à l'heure retourner peut être sympa
ouisou aussi George Smith j'habite à
quelques kilomètres du château de
versaill enfin les clés sous bois c'est
pas très loin le château de versaill
fait l'unanimité oui j'ai l'impression
c'est quand même un symbole dans les
ivelines et effectivement le château de
Versailles ça ça parle à tout le monde
en tout cas pendant les vacances on peut
aussi aller faire du patin à glace voilà
sur une patinoire pendant ces vacances
de Noël bah justement notre Mister météo
local il est aussi national dans notre
cœur c'est Thomas Fletcher qui est parti
tester et même mondial vous avez raison
de souligner Michel il est parti tester
la banquise et des clés sous bois avec
son fidèle acolyte Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude alors quoi de
[Musique]
B
ESS de glisser un petit peu voilà très
bien ou il y a du
progrès progr tu sens
non tu arrivriver à mettre un dauphin ça
rentre pas les dauphins sur le
traînauess l'équipe aloradb s'excuse de
l'incompétence de son cadreur
reconnaissance animalière il est belge
de Belgique il n'a jamais vu de dauphins
suite à un sondage au sein de la
rédaction nous en avons convenu que ce
sont des FS ça rentre pas les dauphins
sur le traau essay
oui voilà ça c'est bien
ridicule tu pourras je sais pas dans le
scénario on pourra dire que tu essayes
de d'aider les dauphins à faire du du
patin glace tu vois non non c'est
toujours des
fus c'est parfait c'est très
[Musique]
bien tu t'assois sur celui du mieux
ouais et et tu prends les deux autres
comme si
c et tu fais le mec qui est fier d'avoir
bien rangé
là c'est tes deux copains les deux
autres voilà B écoute c'est pas
mal
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire le
Père
Noël est-ce que vous faites Mère Noël
non cétait ma seule
questionour la boule ça vaer si vous
voulez bonjour les
enfant on peut vous poser quelques
questions ça marche de faire fais t les
ans est-ceon pourrait avoir une
imitation du soir
même ah
pas combien d'anné
10 ans 10 ans de Père Noël bah oui et
vous Madame Mère Noël non pas du tout
non oh oh
oh ah super bonjour bonjour on cherche
un père Noël oui ah B comment ça j'ai
pas trouvé moi le Père Noël je sais pas
le père fouetard est dans le coin ou pas
une imitation du Père Noël boule oh au
moins oh oh oh que c'est joli le Père
Noël vous pourriez nous imiter un peu le
Père Noël quand même pour voir oua oh oh
oh oh
oh il est celui merci merci oh il arrive
du
ciel pas mal mais vous êtes livreur
ouais mais j'ai pas le temps j'ai un ok
vous faites le faire Noël de temps en
temps ou pas non mais vous livrez quand
même ah ou je livre quand même Père Noël
livre aussi ou je Liv pour mes cents
mais pas pour moi mais Père Noël non
plus fa pas pour lui vous faites quoi le
25 joyeux Noël joyux no merci bonne
journée
on est à 12 minutes 30 d'images oui mais
c'est parfaitement nul c'est ça qui est
génial parce que ça re à
rien et on voit
thomasrière nous Thomas une petite
imitation du Père
Noël j'ai bien apprisis il y a encore du
[Rires]
travail g je pour suivais la musique en
plateau un petit peu ah
oui
[Musique]
hey c'est vraiment impressionnant ouais
c'est impressionnant alors cette année a
été aussi pleine de rebondissement à TV
78 Grégory pendant 1 an nous vous avons
présenté environ 260 émissions du 78 sur
la chaîne on a compté on s'amusait elles
ont parfois été drôles on va le dire et
il y a eu des moments un peu
embarrassants en direct mais aussi en
coulisse je vous propose de regarder le
bêtisier de l'année
[Musique]
2023 on va commencer Véronique par une
une pépite pépite ivelinoise bonjour à
tous et bienvenue dans ce numéro spécial
du Sky ah pardon il y avait des gens qui
passaient derrière toi ça m'a je pas que
tu tombes l'éleectric Park de Chatou
c'est terminé ce soir pour nous vous
avez salon de l'emploi géant toute la
journée une grande attention non tu vas
tomber mais rassurez-vous ça reviendra à
l'année prochaine avec et
l'agglomération de saqutin en iel ont
transformé le site olympique du salon du
salon l'éleectrique parc de Chatou c'est
terminé pour
nous son ambition promouvoir la musique
amplifiée dans
ans en Yveline tuas oublié de partir
j'ai oublié de partir son objectif
promouvoir et développer la musique
amplifiée dans 50 ans en
yeline ça m'énerve et s'il y avait un ou
deux rendez-vous à surtout pas noter on
en a on en a dit quelquesuns il y en a
bien sûr beaucoup d'autres dans la
programmation tattendais pas
[Musique]
on ouais c'est ça on a plus rien je vous
passe un
[Musique]
film après ce repas quoi de mieux qu'une
balade digestive à
quelques et on se trouve et on se trouve
maintenant à
la et on se retrouve tout de suite dev
vient nous expliquer les activités et
parmi elles il y a le karting Mathilde
faut faire attention parce que Nicolas
dandr il avance tout le temps quand il
est devant la caméra
il vous saurez tout des révolutions
techniques et des bouleversements
artistiques et dimanche petite journée
[Musique]
pépère
c'est super bien
présenté alors on continue on continue
avec quoi on va continuer avec la bande
dessinée les comics et les romans
graphiques
[Musique]
allez baisse-toi encore ouais là là tu
es bien ah ouais tu es sexy
même cette arrivée répondait à une
demande de la population l'érection les
réactions au micro de Julien Leroi
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 78 nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv78
nous sommes le lundi 9 septembre 9
octobre
[Musique]
pardon voilà pour le bêtisier de l'année
ça ça résume l'année de manière drôle je
sais pas si vous avez un moment que vous
retenez drôle ou pas d'ailleurs de de
l'année 2023 boule à la fin la boule non
non la boule après sinon bah les
multiples bourdes on peut dire de
Gabriel peut-être on l' pu le voir
dans moi je décerne la palme d'or à
Régine ralche qui fait tomber le
restaurant ça c'est quand même très très
drôle tout on du haut niveau en tout cas
moment vous retenez 2023 pas forcément
drôle mais un reportage peut-être qui ah
un reportage je dirais j'ai suivi maéice
la porte qui devrait participer aux Jeux
olympiques en 2024 une gymnaste
plaisiroise à linp et chez elle c'était
un bon moment Clara même si vous nous
avez rejoint finalement qu'en octobre je
crois c'est bien ça ouais c'est vrai non
moi j'ai beaucoup aimé le championnat de
France de BMX ça c'était vachement sympa
et beaucoup de monde c'était très
impressionnant c'était le premier
weekend de décembre à 50 ans noous
inviter ce que vous retenez un événement
quelque chose de de l'année 2023 George
ben j'ai deux petites filles une qui a
eu son diplôme de
journaliste tout récemment elle est
partie vivre en Suisse elle a trouvé un
job en Suisse et ma deuxème petite fille
qui est en 3e année de vétérinaire et
elle est vraiment très heureuse quoi
félicitations à elle félicitations
Sophie et moi je suis devenue maman
Enation voà de belles choses ouaisom
demander à Thomas évement 2023 Thomas
tous parce que c'était une super année
allez là je sais pas si on l'a entendu
on l'a entendu vous pensez je je pense
que oui oui on confirme en RG
effectivement une une super année en
votre compagnie ça a été en tout cas un
plaisir de présenter cette
émission C H fin d'année qui touche à sa
fin merci aux téléspectateurs de nous
avoir suivi merci à nos invités Sophie
benabi à George Schmith on remercie
aussi le Père Noël qui est venu
dans sur ce sur ce plateau merci à
Gabriel Clara Michel merci à vous merci
aussi aux équipes techniques qui sont
derrière en coulisse mais qui
participent à la bonne tenue de cette
émission et merci à notre reine de Noël
un petit peu farceur derrière c'est
Thomas fler avec son météo reine de Noël
avec son beau costume voilà météo qui
nous a encore amusé cette année sur tv78
en tout cas on vous souhaite de belles
fêtes de fin d'année prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous